learn how to create a wave defense game
without coding using gdevelop gdevelop
is a no code open source game engine
this beginner tutorial covers player
movement firing a bullet enemy logic
spawning enemies and more there's a link
in the description to download all the
free assets used in this game in this
video I'm going to go over how to make a
wave defense game with gdevelop the no
code open source game engine
so here I've created a blank project
no events no objects no nothing
the first thing I need to do
is change the properties
because the assets I'm using are
designed
for 768
by 432.
now the first thing I'm going to do is
set up the area we'll be playing in
this is going to be a wave defense game
starting out on a single screen
so I'll create the Sprite object for the
floor
all right
now I'm going to go to the event sheet
and at the beginning of scene
I'm going to zoom the camera in and then
Center that camera on the object
foreign
and there we go
I just realized I need to change the
properties for importing assets
if you saw the image was a little blurry
because it's pixel art
and so now that I've imported that image
in I need to change the smoothing
all right there we go
nice and crisp
so now that I have the room I'm going to
add the Sprite object for the player
character
one animation being for run
and the other being a single frame for
idle
I'll put the idle animation first so
it's the first one that plays
now for the Running Animation I'll need
to set this to Loop
and find a speed that makes sense
yeah there we go
I'll press apply
and now I've got a little armless
character in scene
to get it to move around I need to give
it the top down movement Behavior
which is right here
I'll leave all of its variables alone
oh wait nope
I need to change that variable
rotate object needs to be turned off
there we go
now to animate that character I need to
go to the event sheet where I'm going to
use two different events where if the
character is moving we'll change the
animation
[Music]
and if it's not we'll change it to idle
so now if the character is moving
the animation will play running
and if it's not moving it'll be idle
here we go
now the next thing for a wave defense
game is the gun
so I'm going to add the gun in as a
separate object
[Music]
and put it into the scene
next I'll need to go to the player
and give it a point
I'll just call it gun
and then move that point down to the
center ish where the hands would be
that's good for now
and now I've got to go to the event
sheet and tell the gun to be positioned
at that point
so to get that point I'll type in player
point
quotations
and then I can select gun
alternatively I could do this
y position of point
select the player
and then select gun
it's the same way to get it but once you
get used to typing it in you just do
that
and we also want the gun to rotate
towards the mouse
so I'll use the cursor X
and the cursor y
and the speed will be zero so it happens
immediately
and now if I preview the game
you'll see the gun is rotating towards
the mouse
but the position is a little bit off
and the reason for that is simple
the origin point of the gun is in the
top left so if I'm positioning the gun
on that point on the character it should
be in the center
which in this case is 14x8
here we go
gun is in the center
now the next thing I want to do is have
the character flip
so to do that we'll set it up so that if
the mouse is on the right hand side of
the character
they'll look right and if they're on the
left hand side of the character they'll
look left
[Music]
so we need to check if the mouse is
above or below the X position of the
character
so on the right or the left
[Music]
okay let's see if I did that right
nope that's backwards
there we go now for the gun
now the gun will want to do the opposite
four because it's already rotating
towards the mouse we need to flip it
vertically for it to make sense
and there we go
character moves is animated and the gun
follows the mouse
the next thing to do is firing a bullet
so we thankfully have a wonderful
extension in gdevelop
if I go to the behaviors and go to
search for new behaviors I can look for
the
fire bullet extension
and add that
it comes with a lot of great things but
we don't need any of it right now
we just need to add a bullet object
which is just another Sprite object
and then add an event for firing the
bullet when I release the left Mouse
button
[Music]
and I find for this it's best to have it
so that the bullet Fires at the angle
the gun is facing
[Music]
so we'll be creating a bullet
but we need an X and Y position to
create the bullet at
so for that we'll go to the gun and add
another point
and we'll drag it right there
if I go back in I can use the Expression
Builder
and get the X point
and get the Y point
we'll angle the bullet at the same angle
as the gun
and set it to go at a speed of 100.
oh there we go
it's a little bit off but that's because
we haven't set the center point
[Music]
there we go
now I just need to set it up so that it
only happens when I release the left
Mouse button
all right
and now for the sake of performance
we'll make it so that the bullets delete
after they get off screen
and there is an extension for this but I
found it's easier to just use the
distance from the player if the camera
follows the player then once the bullet
gets a certain distance away from the
player it's off screen
[Music]
whoops
this event needs to be inverted in order
to work
there we go you see it gets deleted once
it gets a certain distance away from the
player
[Music]
there we go
object picking
so now we need to change that so it's
wider than the screen
and that'll do it
now for enemies I'll create another
Sprite object for the enemy
[Music]
okay then I'll add the health behavior
to the enemy so we can easily kill it
I need to search this one up with the
extensions again
and just like firing a bullet there's
lots of variables in there to play with
but we just need the health and that's
it
so I'll set the starting Health to three
and the maximum as well
and now in the event sheet
we'll set it up so that if the bullet is
in collision with the Enemy
foreign
we delete the bullet
and then subtract one Health from the
enemy
by using the apply damage to an enemy
action
there we go and the last thing we do is
check if the enemy is dead and if they
are dead delete them
there we go
one two three
now we'll want to change the Collision
masks on these two objects
so that they fit the image more
[Music]
foreign
and that just makes more sense
and now the next thing I'm going to do
is have the enemies spawn outside of
screen and come in and we'll have them
do that towards some Center object in
the middle whether it be a baby or a pet
rabbit or whatever
I'm gonna be doing the spawning with
spawn points as points for the enemies
to spawn at
and now in the events I need to set up a
timer that will repeat and when it
finishes repeating it will pick one of
these points and spawn an enemy there
[Music]
foreign
so to make this spawn at a different
point each time
we need to add the condition pick a
random object
and now every time that timer hits one
second it will pick a random spawn point
and create the enemy at that point and
then we need to reset the timer
okay we can't see it so hold on
here we go
one two
three four
okay now the enemies need to spawn and
move towards the center object so we're
going to apply a permanent Force to get
them there
making sure not to use the physics Force
because we're not using the physics
engine
[Music]
so now we have the enemy moving towards
the
center with a permanent force of 20
pixels per second
there we go
[Music]
and now to give the game a fail State
we'll set it so that when the ghost is
in collision with that Center Point the
game scene restarts
and we're doing that by just changing
the game scene to what it is already
so if we start it and they run into the
center point the game will just restart
oh that's something to fix
gonna set it so that the
screen doesn't expand
and there we go that's the beginnings of
a wave defense game
and now with the basic setup done we're
going to move on to some game polish
fixing up some of the weaker points of
the game adding some sound effects and
shake and all of the things that make a
game feel good to play the first thing I
need to do though is go to the event
sheet and organize a little bit because
this is going to get a bit chaotic if we
don't organize from the beginning
[Music]
always check to make sure things are
still working the way they're supposed
to
yep good now we can begin so the first
thing that we're going to do is deal
with Z ordering and the position of the
enemies because we want our enemies to
be looking at the position they're going
to rather than just off in the distance
so for Z ordering we're going to do
something that makes a lot more sense
when you see it in the action
so we're going to go to The Ghost and
move its origin Point down to the center
bottom right there this is going to be
the point where Z ordering kicks in and
determines whether the ghost will be in
front of or behind other objects in the
scene
and we'll do the same thing for the
player as well
[Music]
now there is an extension for Z ordering
but I personally don't like it because
it means you have to add the behavior to
every single enemy or object that needs
to be affected personally I just like to
put things into a group and use that
group for the ordering
okay so now that we have this and all
the points have been changed and
everything is in a group we just need a
single action for Z ordering where we
tell the Z order of the player and the
other objects to be equal to their y
position which is the Y position of
their origin point which is now at their
feet
[Music]
and that's it
now when I press preview and the go
start to show in nope uh one second
[Music]
there we go I had to change the gun Z
order to be one above the player so it
doesn't go behind them
all right now as the ghosts spawn in
I'll be able to walk up to them and show
you the Z ordering happening and you can
already see it with these two ghosts the
one that's lowered down is behind the
one that's ahead of it
but if I go to this ghost I'll be hot
nope
one second
okay if I go to this ghost
and behind it now and now I'm in front
of it behind in front behind in front
behind in front and it's gonna happen
for all the ghosts in the scene to help
give the game depth so things look like
they make sense
all right now I want to make it so that
the ghosts are facing towards the center
point so they're not going backwards
[Music]
okay so I've set it up so that if the
enemy is
to the right of the center point
it'll flip and it's to the left it won't
flip
so that way when they spawn in from the
spawning action
it'll check this and then flip them
accordingly
and there we go now they're all looking
at the center point when they spawn in
so they're not going in backwards like
they were before
the next thing I would like to do is
give them health bars
and there are a lot of ways to do this
like you could use the prefab objects
that we already have in game and that's
a great option but I'd probably use that
for the player because the player is
going to need to adjust for different
things and get healed and so on but just
for an enemy health bar you can just use
a Sprite object
[Music]
actually it's probably better to use a
tiled Sprite for this
you got to put in the size of your
object or the image
[Music]
and now we'll want to spawn these in
over the ghosts whenever we spawn in a
ghost
so we'll be creating the health bar when
we create a ghost object
and then we'll be using the action to
link that health bar to the ghost which
will let us do something later
and because The Ghost and the health bar
created at the same time when we tell it
to link it's going to link two of those
objects together because they've already
been picked and it will ignore all of
the other ones in scene
so now that it's linked I can make an
event that positions
[Music]
ah shoot you know what this is actually
easier with a Sprite object because a
Sprite object you can change the center
point hold on
foreign
[Music]
first because it will get rid of the
events in the event sheet we just need
to change it to
the new object
and now delete the old one
okay there we go now
we want to position the object using
both the X and Y positions
and we actually want to use a point on
the ghost object
so we need to put that point in call
this health bar
and we want that to be above the ghost
in the center
I should probably do it and we want to
change the health bars origin to the
center
depending on the kind of game that
you're working on this may be a thing
you need to do all the time or not at
all
so now that we have the point somebody
asked about this in the last video so
I'm going to show you
this is just a regular position action
it's not a position to a point or
anything like that it's just a regular
position action in the position section
of the actions
and then here we can press on the
Expression Builder
search point
click on the X position of a point
select the ghost enemy object
Select Health bar
because that's the point that we just
made
and then do the same thing for the Y
position
so now we have the X and Y position of
that point
so the health bar will be positioned at
The X and Y position of that point on
the enemy object
but to make sure it picks the right
ghost to be above we need to use the
condition take into account linked
objects
and there we go
now let's see if that worked
it should be cut oh no no health bars
no health bars
let's see what's going wrong
we'll just disable that
oh
the other ones are being left behind one
enemy has their health bar
okay
[Music]
there we go okay so now we have each
health bar following each ghost
what I had to do was use the repeat for
each instance of enemy or whatever
object you want event
so this way for every single ghost on
the scene
it's going to take into account if the
health bar is linked with the Enemy and
then position that health bar on top of
that enemy
so before it was doing it for one enemy
and because it was doing it and doing it
for one enemy it was content because it
was doing what it was supposed to do I
didn't tell it to do it multiple times
so it did it once and it was okay
and now we're going to need to delete
those health bars because otherwise
they're going to get left behind when
the ghost dies
watch
now just floats there
so when the ghost is dead
take into account the link
and delete
the health bar
and
didn't work
there we go no no I deleted all of them
[Music]
okay there we go
don't judge me I've only had three
coffees
let me just link that object picking
video again up in the top corner
so now
the health bar deletes when the enemy
does part of the problem was if I put it
up here
yeah
so if I put the enemy above the event
then this happens first
and there's no enemy to check
for this action
if I put it down here then the health
bar gets deleted first and then the
enemy
now we're gonna do a hit animation and
we're going to start by giving the ghost
a knockback animation
we'll call the first one walking
and the next one
hurt
there we go now when the enemy gets hit
with a bullet will change their
animation to hurt
[Music]
change it by name
and
we'll make an event that checks to see
if the enemy's animation is hurt and if
it's finished
and if that's the case we'll change this
animation back to walking or floating I
guess but we're gonna make other enemies
and it's going to make more sense then
okay and the last thing we're going to
do is make it so that if the enemy is
hurt they stop walking which actually
means that we need to change the way
enemies go towards the center point so
instead of moving them with the
permanent Force
we're going to change this so that if
the enemy's animation is not hurt
so if the enemy's animation is not hurt
we'll use an instant Force instead to
move the enemy
there we go
let me just fix the zoom
not disabled anymore
there we go
oh whoops
So currently when you add a new
animation to an object it has those
original origin points because it
doesn't want to conflict with the
existing ones
so we can go to the animations go to
hurt
just use the same points as the
animations
nope not this one hold on hold on
I need to go to walking
flip this switch
turn it on there we go
and now this one has it if I done it the
other way around it would have applied
this image's points to the other one
which this one only had its origin point
and Center so that would have been a bad
thing
cool so now both animations have the
same points and can be used as we want
them to
here we go so shoot it
hurt
dead
okay so you might have seen there that
when I shot a ghost and it was already
in her animation it didn't change or
react and so now I've changed it so that
when that animation triggers it's
actually going to set the frame to zero
so if it's already in that animation
it's going to restart it
so I said three one two three
one two
I'll try to show a good example of it
happening
and I noticed the Z order for the health
bars were kind of off so we need to fix
that too
[Music]
so we'll change the Z order for the
health barriers to be equal to the
enemies Z order
uh Plus
one sure
actually if we make it even then it will
be like a flat image and that will work
out better
let's see if that worked
no it it didn't work
it doesn't know which one to check
[Music]
okay
now this isn't a big deal but for
performance I should probably do this
that way we don't have the same event
triggering twice checking every single
enemy
so now within a single event where we're
checking to see if the enemies are
linked to the health bar
and then changing the position and
changing the z-order
[Music]
so first we need to make the health bar
represent the actual health of the ghost
so when they get hit
[Music]
take into account the link
and we don't need the four each for this
one because we've already got the ghost
picked
and we'll change the width of the
sprayed object to equal the current
health divided by the max Health times
the original size
and to get that we can use the
Expression Builder
this is using the health extension so if
you haven't got that extension installed
this won't be there so the health points
of the enemy that's the current health
divided by
maximum health
of the enemy
times the original width which is 12
pixels
because if we go back to the object
and open it with piscal
we can see it's 12 pixels wide
so it's the current divided by Max times
12.
and we'll see how that works
there we go
one shot left boom gone
[Music]
so now that the health bar is working
I'm going to adjust the speed and
everything of the character and that's
in the top down Behavior
because that's what we're using to move
the character
[Music]
all right
next I'll add the collisions for the
walls because someone asked for that in
the comments
I'm going to add a sprayed object for
that and just spread it out over the
walls
[Music]
okay now I can go to the event sheet
and go to the players group
ment
and make it so the player gets separated
from the wall
and the player is the first object so
that it gets moved and not the wall when
separating the two objects
all right now when I go in
I cannot walk past the walls
[Music]
there we go now it looks like I can walk
up to the wall
but I get stopped down here
I could have gone into the room itself
gone to the Collision mask
and added in several different kinds of
collision masks for the walls
which I've done before but honestly it's
a slow way to do it
if you're just using a single room like
this or something static it's just
easier to build out a collision mask
like this with a separate object
it just means that at the beginning of
scene you need to hide it
and it's gone but I still can't walk
past him the player just can't see it
and while we're doing collisions we
should probably also do the ghost enemy
foreign
so here in the ghost enemy object we can
make a new event and then use the action
to separate two objects to make it so
that the enemy
is separated from the group entities
[Music]
yeah there we go
so you can see they're pushing away from
each other
I just noticed actually hold on
I never changed the Collision mask
so I go to this one yeah it's the full
size of the image
so I need to go to this one which is the
Collision mask that I once shared
and toggle it on
and this will share same Collision masks
for all animations which means if I go
to this one it'll be that
so now when I shoot them it doesn't push
them all away they do stop though
because there's something in front of
them trying to stop them from moving
and that way they won't be able to
overlap and group up like they did
before
and now up to this point I've been able
to
spam the bullet as fast as I can click
it'll spawn
well if we go to the gun and go to the
fire bullet Behavior you can see that
the cooldown is 0.1 seconds and we can
just change that to 0.5 or something
like that
foreign
and because there's a cool down on there
we can change this to actually be Mouse
button is pressed instead
so that way we can hold on to the button
and it'll fire at that fire rate
you don't want to go too fast with
bullets because there's a chance for
them to clip through the object
before it gets recognized as a collision
but that's pretty good
and now for firing a bullet let's add a
sound effect
we can use the condition has just fired
for the gun to play a sound
I don't have one picked yet so I'm going
to go to create one
and I'm just going to pick something
randomly until I get something good
so we'll call that gun
save
volume and
of course randomized pitch
because if you have a sound that plays
repeatedly you need to make sure that it
randomizes so it doesn't drive your
player nuts
so 0.8 to 1 means it'll be a little bit
less or exactly the pitch of what it was
before
all right now there's a secret weapon
for all game devs out there who might
want this
camera Shake
[Music]
and now we can go into the events and
add in screen shake when the bullet has
been fired
[Music]
it's a bit too intense
so we need to change the settings to
make it a little bit less annoying and
we do this by going in and having an
action
and we do this by going in and using the
action to change certain aspects of the
shake
[Music]
alright so now that we've set up the
camera settings using the actions at the
beginning of scene
we have something that's pretty okay
to cover up those edges we're going to
change the background color
so we'll go to piscal
use the Color Picker tool to get the
color
and then apply that color to the
background
and there we go now when the screen
shakes you can't see those edges anymore
now one more thing that we can add in is
some object shake for the gun
and that again is an extension called
shake shake object
put that on the gun
and then in the event sheet at the point
where the gun is fired we'll set it so
the gun shakes along with the screen to
add to the effect
[Music]
and let's see what that looks like
okay now one more thing I'm going to add
in is my secret weapon so I'm going to
add in a vignette
turn the grid back on so it goes in
place properly
and to make sure the vignette stays
above everything I'm going to put it on
a different layer
select the vignette go to properties and
change the layer to vignette
now I will need to zoom in because
otherwise it will do this
because the main game Zooms in and the
vignette doesn't
and there we go so now on the edges of
the screen the character is a little bit
darker
and on the inside it's a little brighter
and now that we've brought the game up
to a certain level of Polish we're going
to add menus and settings to the game to
make it a more complete package
so let's get started
so the first thing we need to do is go
to another scene for the main menu
I'll start by adding a bitmap text
because the resolution of this game is a
little bit smaller than you would
normally make
the regular text object would look
blurry in this setting so you really
want to use a bitmap text if you're
using any resolution that's not at least
1280.
for bitmap text you need the bitmap font
and an atlas image
and the font basically tells the engine
how to break up the image to turn it
into a font and the image can actually
be edited with any kind of image editing
software
so you can make some pretty fancy custom
text with bitmap text
and now I'll just copy that to make some
extra buttons for the menu
[Music]
before I make the rest of the text
objects I'm going to install the
extension button States
and add it to the play text object
because then I can use that as a button
[Music]
in the event sheet I can use is clicked
as a condition for future events
now I'm going to create a marker object
that I can use to Center the camera on
[Music]
and I'm going to create two of these so
that when I press settings I can tween
over to the next section of the menu and
show the settings
so I've got the main menu part and the
settings part
[Music]
and from here I can use the user
interface objects like the toggle switch
buttons and Sliders to create my
settings menu
and I'm going to start with the sliders
[Music]
all right and from here when I press
settings it's going to Tween the camera
over to the settings menu
[Music]
okay animated settings marker object
because otherwise I would need to use
variables to decide which one was which
and this is less complicated
so we'll be tweening between the marker
for the main menu and the marker for the
settings menu
[Music]
and there we go
so we're tweening to the center X of
this bar
and the camera's Center y position which
is already at
so that won't change and now I'm going
to set it up so that when I press back
we go back to that original menu
[Music]
and there we go
and actually I'm going to set it up so
that the title stays in place while the
menu changes just as a personal
preference
so I'm going to make a new layer called
title and then put that title object on
that layer so it won't be affected when
the camera tweens
all right
next I'm going to hide those bars
[Music]
okay
and now the rest of the buttons
[Music]
thank you
so now when the play button is clicked
it will change the scene to the Untitled
scene which is our original game scene
and when the back button is clicked
we'll quit the game
here we go
and
[Music]
when the quit button is clicked we'll
quit the game
[Music]
there we go
so now all the buttons do something
now let's make the settings do something
so we're going to create some Global
variables
we'll make a structure
call this settings
make one for Sound and Music
all right
now go back into the event sheet and
make it so that the value of the sound
bar or the music bar dictates that
variable
and we'll use the Expression Builder to
get the value for that bar
okay so when the sound slider bar is
being dragged
we change the global variable
sound settings that we just made to
equal the value of that bar
and we'll do the same thing for music
alright so now when the music slider is
being dragged it'll change that value
and if there is music being currently
played or sounds being played while that
slider is being moved and you want them
to dynamically shift you'll need to
change that as well
using one of the actions for volume of
the music or Sound on that channel
so you'd slap that in right here
but for sound effects
we'll use this setting when playing
those
so if we go back into the main game
and find the point where the sound for
the gun is played
will change the volume
to equal that Global variable
so now when we change that setting it's
going to affect this sound when it gets
played
so now if I open the menu
and go to settings
I can change sounds to be up here at 100
go back
press play
you can hear the sound played
but if I go to the menu
go to settings
change the sound down low
to just above zero
it's been turned down
but every time I go into the game it's
going to be back at that same level
again
so we need to save and load that in and
it's been a little while since I've done
this so bear with me
so we'll be writing a text and we'll be
writing that entire setting structure
into a save file outside of the game
so settings
so when we click back it's going to
write settings into an external folder
or external file outside of the game
[Music]
and then at the beginning of the scene
we'll read this text settings from the
storage settings and store it as a
temporary settings text
and then we can add the action to parse
or convert this text into our Global
variables
so we select the settings structure
and then we're going to change the
position of that slider bar based on the
new value
[Music]
so we're setting the sound slider and
music slider to the global variables
that we just read into the engine
and converted two Global variables
because they come in as scene variables
and then we use those global variables
to set the value on those slider bars
so let's try that out
okay now press back and that's going to
be where we save the settings
so now they're saved
so if I exit
and preview it again and go to settings
they didn't save
[Music]
okay I know what I was doing wrong
so it's not just a string of the
structure
you need to actually convert the global
variable to a Json
first
now slight settings
apply
so now it's saved as a Json then it's
going to get read back in and yeah okay
preview
settings
set the settings
back
quit
preview
settings and there where they were
before awesome okay so now the settings
are saved
when we come back in
same thing when we go play the game
if I skip back to here
settings they're saved okay
great so they save
as a Json
here
and then the red back into the engine as
a temporary file
in the scene variables and then they get
converted from that Json to a readable
Global variable in settings
cool
and then these two actions change the
sliders to represent what they actually
are
cool
cool cool
now the next thing is highlighting
so when you hover over a button it
lights up
if you have a button object this will
happen the way it does already it just
changes the animation for the object one
of these objects here the panel Sprite
buttons
but if you're using text like this
you instead need to add an effect to it
so we'll just add this to all of our
buttons
[Music]
and then we'll create a group and call
it buttons
[Music]
and we'll add two events one for if the
button is hovered then the effect is on
and if the button is not hovered then
the effect is off
we'll use the group
okay
all right so if the button is hovered
it's on and if the button is not hovered
it is off
[Music]
and if the button is not hovered it is
off
here we go
all right now just make this blend in
with the actual game itself
we'll snag this color
and drop it in here there we go now
really quickly the last thing I want to
do is add a transition really quickly so
for this we're going to go to the
extension list and add an extension for
transition
and with that installed we're going to
add a paint shaper object
change the fill color to Black
and I'll put it in the scene so it's
there
now
we need to give it the behavior first
so now when the play button is clicked
[Music]
thank you
okay and we'll change this so that when
the transition finishes
then we will change scenes
we'll want to put this on the
title layer so it's above everything
else above the title specifically
okay
and you'll notice on the edges
it doesn't reach the edges before the
transition happens
I've noticed that to be a thing that can
be tweaked
so we're going to go to add layer
call this transition
transition layer
and then at the beginning of scene Zoom
camera
transition layer
by 1.5
now it goes to the edge of the screen
and then for the other side
we'll do the same thing
so we can just set this to be a global
object
awesome
go over here place this into scene
add a transition layer
put this onto it
and then do the same thing
the only difference is that we need to
do the reverse now for the transition so
it shrinks instead of expands
so we'll set this to Circular again
and backwards this time instead of
forwards
so when this scene starts
nope oh
this is in seconds one second
there we go okay
so
now when we press play
does this and then this and we're into
the game
now with the menus and settings done
we're going to move on to some more game
mechanics and we're starting with
leveling up
the very first thing that we need is a
leveling bar and thankfully G develop
has one in the asset store that will
match this game's style already
we just need to put it on a different
layer
so it's above all of the gameplay
[Music]
alright now we need to make some scene
variables for leveling up
the first one's of course being the
current and maximum experience for
leveling up and then all of the stats we
want to actually level up
[Music]
start with something small for the
maximum experience points
and now we need to link the resource bar
object with those stats
[Music]
and there we go now it's 0 out of 10
because 10 was the amount of experience
you need to actually level up but now we
need experience points
and for that I'm going to create a new
Sprite object and just make a little
white dot to use as the experience point
[Music]
that is way too big
that's much better okay
and now we'll make it so that the ghosts
drop these whenever they die
[Music]
there we go and then we need to be able
to pick them up to use them as EXP
[Music]
foreign
let's see if that worked
there we go
now when we kill a ghost
and get close enough to the
experience point it adds it to our scene
variable which is used to control the
EXP bar
but running this every single frame
would be a lot so we're going to change
this to this
and this
so it's only doing that whenever we
actually run into any XP point
and to fix this at the beginning of
scene I'm just going to change the
default values of the bar
so now they line up
but that's not very fun to look at so
we're going to change this so that the
points go to you whenever you get close
enough and then when they get really
close to you they'll actually get picked
up
[Music]
thank you
and there we go
maybe a little faster though
so now we're able to level up
but what happens when we actually reach
the max level
currently nothing
but I'm going to create a new layer with
some buttons on it to spend points
whenever we level up
[Music]
again adding the bitmap font that I
added in earlier
and because people have been asking this
font plus all the assets will be
available in a folder in the description
from now on so you can actually follow
along yourself
[Music]
thank you
all right so now we have a text object
that says power fire rate and accuracy
that we can modify when we update the
stats and buttons that we can actually
use for those stats
one for power one for fire rate and then
one for accuracy
and then for accuracy we actually need
to tank the accuracy to make it make
sense
we'll change this to
20 and see how that does
zero would be perfect accuracy 20 is off
by an angle of 20.
that might be a bit too much but it's
fine for now
alright so we'll hide the level up layer
and then in the event sheet make it so
that when the current exp level hits the
max we'll pause the game show that layer
and then when they spend their point on
that thing go back to the game again
I always set it to greater than or equal
to or less than or equal to just in case
something happens where you pick up two
with the exact same frame or something
like that
it's just safer that way
[Music]
all right so now when we hit the maximum
number for the XP we'll set the time
scale to zero
show the level up layer
and then set the current exp back to
zero so we start over again
and while we're doing this it's a good
idea to have the scaling happen here
so we'll change the scene variable for
the max exp to something like
twice of what it currently is
there we go so now when this happens
well let me just show you actually
oh
I need to be good at the game to
actually show you I guess
[Music]
and there we go now we've
now the game is frozen and this should
fix itself once that's done
and we can press on these buttons
no we can't we can't do that yet
um
okay so we need to add this part into
the actual event sheet and while I'm at
it I need to add a darkening layer here
so it's not
this bright
[Music]
okay so I used a
shape painter object to make a black
rectangle the size of the screen and
then change its the order to be lower
than everything else on that layer
and we'll change this to 180
and that way it won't be completely
black it'll be transparent and you'll be
able to see the background
so the next thing we'll do is make it so
that the buttons actually do something
and when you press them you go back to
the game with the improved stats
I'll put all of the buttons into a group
to make it easier
[Music]
now because we have the button State
Extension installed
you can see two of them but this is for
the panel spray buttons and this is for
the button State Extension
[Music]
so now when one of these buttons gets
pressed we'll hide the level player
change the scale back to one
and then update the bar
but now for the actual leveling up part
so because we have the
nope
the gun object with the behavior on it
for fire bullet this is what we'll be
updating
so we'll be changing the fire cooldown
rate
and the angle variance whenever we
change the level of the stat
but also we're going to do that for when
we hit the enemy
so right now it's applying one point of
damage to the enemy but we're going to
change that to the stat for power so
that when they get hit they take more
than one hit worth of damage
[Music]
thank you
so for the accuracy I've changed the
angle variance which is how much it'll
Miss by by multiplying it by the angle
variance which I got using the
Expression Builder times 0.9
so each time this gets picked it's going
to hack off 10 percent of the current
value which means as this level gets
higher the accuracy getting added to it
is going to be less and less as it gets
closer and closer to zero which is
perfect accuracy
foreign
[Music]
and then I did the same thing for the
firing cooldown which is the fire rate
so we'll be changing the stat number in
the scene variables
so we can use that for displaying it but
the actual change is happening
here in this second action
whereas for the power variable we're
actually going to change that up above
so right here where the enemies are
taking damage
get rid of that one and change it to
scene variable
for power
so now they'll be taking the power as
your
damage instead of one
and the last thing I want to do is
change it so that the stats actually
changed in the level up page
so for that I'm going to go here again
copy this
come back here and go to bitmap
to change the text of the bitmap object
stats equal
quotations
and this is going to get a little messy
but bear with me
so the one
quotations
power
so we got the power stat Plus
so now it's going to show Power to here
plus this variable for power
and then we'll add a plus here
and another quotation
[Music]
there we go
and so now it's this and then down here
we'll do the same thing
I'll just copy all of this
paste it
get rid of the Plus on this end because
this will be the end of it
and the coordination
and then this will be changed to
this is the fire rate
and the accuracy is being changed to the
accuracy there we go so now power fire
rates accuracy
showing the variables for power fire
rate and accuracy
let's see if that worked
[Music]
um
that is not how it's supposed to go
that accuracy is quite a bit worse
okay
ah
setu and
set to
there we go okay
let's try that
okay yeah there we go
oh
and the power is by default at zero so
let's change that as well
we'll set all of these to one to start
with
okay and I'm actually gonna add a cheat
down here
I usually put my cheats down in the
bottom of the screen so I'll change it
so that if the K key is pressed we'll
change the current
variable two variable
scene variable Max exp so we'll just set
it straight to Max exp when I press k
okay
so when the game starts I'll pick
accuracy press k
and we'll level up instantly
I'll press fire rate and now it's
changed to 20. so on the second level
it'll take 20 to level up
I'll press K again
upgrade power
announce two two and two
upgrade power again
and when I shoot this ghost it should
die in one hit
yeah
and that's because now the power is
level three so we're doing three points
of damage when we hit them
and the fire rate should be up let's try
to crank that up
oh yeah that's way faster
accuracy is a little bit too much I
think though
I may need to turn that down a bit more
[Music]
okay I just noticed that the background
darkening layer isn't showing up so I
need to fix that and the problem is that
it's drawing it right here
but it's only doing that once because
this is only true for one frame
and if we go to the paint shaper object
no not for transition for darken
uh it is clearing the rendered image
between each frame so it's only doing it
once for a single frame and then
disappearing so I'm going to turn this
off
and turn that off
because I don't want it relative to the
actual position of the object in scene
and
I'm going to change this to be at the
beginning of scene instead so it does it
once at the beginning of scene and then
doesn't clear it away afterwards
and we'll see if that works
so now if I press k
huh
oh
because the base layer is zoomed in and
this is zero so that's why it's pulled
over to the left okay so I need to
change this to the
level up layer
there we go
because there's two different cameras
the base layer is zoomed in and the
level of layer is not zoomed in
there we go so now it's the whole size
of the level up layers camera
and if I press power it goes away
and level up again it's there great
I might change this to be down here
though
my changes to here
instead of here
so when I level up
yeah it does it automatically and it's
already down to zero
yeah there we go
now that leveling up is done we're going
to go ahead and add some more enemies to
the game to give it some more variety
we'll stick with basic enemy behaviors
for now but we'll add some more
interesting behaviors later
so let's get started currently there's
just the one enemy type so I'm going to
add two more Sprite objects with the
same kind of animations and variables to
go along with it
so I'm just going to copy this one and
change out the images
[Music]
foreign
I'm going to put them all into a group
and I'm going to call it enemies
the game they should react just like
oh no wait hold on
okay so in the event sheet I can swap
out anything that was called ghost enemy
and change it to enemies the group
make sure that's the right spelling
all right and if I press replace
all of these points here should all be
changed to enemies of the group instead
[Music]
just need to double check that it
actually worked
okay now if I start the game
they're getting hurt they're going
towards it
obviously the health bar is breaking
because they weren't supposed to have
that
there we go
okay
so that worked out now we need to be
able to spawn those enemies in separate
from the way that we spawn in ghosts and
for that I'm actually going to implement
a wave system
so I'm going to add a text object
called a wave number
uh pick the same font I guess
and we'll put it on the UI layer
there we go
and now we'll create a new timer
call it wave
and then add an event
where we check if the timer is above
let's try five seconds just for testing
and we'll create a scene variable
call it wave as well have it start at
one
and we'll change this to one
okay
and add the action to change the scene
variable
Wave by adding one to it
all right there we go
and we'll change the enemy's spawning
rate to equal the wave so the higher the
wave is the faster enemies will spawn
let's say three seconds
divided by the variable of wave
variable is just the scene variable
of wave
so every five seconds that will go up
and we will
modify the text of the wave number to
equal in quotations wave
Plus
that
um
oh it needs to be a text variable so
we will change this to we'll search
through the Expression Builder to get it
because it's easier
scene variable
number
wave
there we go it adds the tostring for us
to make it a text instead of a number
okay
now let's try that
[Music]
all right so one enemy spawned
because we're on Wave one so it's three
divided by one so it's three seconds
this didn't change
uh they seem to be coming in faster
oh no they no they're not
need to reset this
and change the scene variable to be
equal to one
this needs to be wave as well
wave
there we go okay now try this
okay so there's one enemy we're on Wave
three now
so I should get one every second
from wave four so I should get one every
three-fourths of a second
and it's going to speed up to the point
where it's Gonna Get Ridiculous
Okay cool so that works but we'll change
this to something more reasonable like
30 seconds
now on top of this I'm going to change
this to the health of the enemies is
going to actually change along with it
so when we're here and we create the
enemy
we'll change the health
of that enemies group to equal
3 plus
that wave variable
divided by three
and rounded down
okay so floral rounded down if it's less
than a whole number so when we're on
Wave three the enemies will have four
health because it'll be three plus one
and then it won't go up again until we
reach wave six when they'll have five
health and so on and so on
okay
change that there we want to change the
maximum and their current health as well
change their health points to equal
their Max health
[Music]
okay
now let's try that out so we need to get
to wave four to see this work in action
oh
we'll change this to five again
and do that
[Music]
one two three
one two three one two three
wave four
one two three four one two three four
one two three four
one two three
oh there we go okay
you get the idea
so when this enemy is created
their Max health and current health get
changed based on the wave variable
and now to make it so that the enemies
spawn at different wave levels
to do this we'll add another scene
variable
properties scene variable
add
I'll just call it random enemy
and then when enemies get spawned I'll
use an event to change that number so it
picks a different enemy
nope
so we use random in range
so it'll pick a whole number
zero two and we'll need a little bit of
algebra for this if we want a new enemy
to show up every three waves then we can
do it the same way that we did it for
the health so let's go there
maximum health
we'll steal this
copy
okay paste in here so now
when an enemy gets created this scene
variable is going to change from zero
to whatever this will be
so if we're below the third wave it will
be less than a whole number so it'll get
rounded down to zero so this will be
zero zero
if we're at wave three to six or three
to five this will round down to one so
it'll be zero to one
and then if we're on wave six or above
or six to eight this will round down to
two so it'll be zero two so it'll be
zero one or two
and then we want to stop there because
if we go beyond that we'll have more
numbers than we have enemies for
so for that
we'll use min
which is another expression that's
wonderful to have
uh we need a comma right
here yep there we go and then two
nope
what
um
ah there we go okay brackets okay so now
it's zero or
the wave variable divided by three
rounded down
and then
Min so it'll pick the smallest number
out of the two options which is either
this or two which means if the variable
forward the wave goes above nine which
would turn this into
three which is more enemies than we
actually have
Instead This Min expression will change
this to two so it'll pick two instead of
the three because it's the smaller
number okay
so this is either 0 or whatever Enemy
Number we're at
and now we need to modify this quite a
bit by moving all of this down here
we'll use the scene variable
as the condition
scene variable for random enemy
and if it equals zero
we'll spawn
the ghost enemy
and since it's already at zero by
default then it's going to pick the
ghost enemy for the first three waves
and then on the
if it picks one
will spawn oh
will spawn the spider
and if it picks three
or two sorry
we'll spawn the Imp
okay we'll see if this works
so we should only see ghosts for the
first three waves
oh
there's a spider the spider stole the
health bar
ah this should be changed to enemies
it must not have been changed with the
search bar
okay so now I need to make these apply
to each enemy type so I'm going to
shuffle these around and change the
names so they work with each enemy as
they spawn
and now I can copy this down for each
enemy
[Music]
okay so now when the number gets picked
for the enemy
it creates the enemy object
and then applies the health and creates
the health bar and links it to that
specific enemy
and it'll do that for each one
and then regardless of which one gets
picked it's going to reset the timer
and pick a new number so the next time
it'll be a new number and we get a
different enemy
now let's see if that worked
here come the ghosts and the first three
waves
more ghosts oh they're spiders
or spiders
they each have individual health bars
and Chris power
it's hard to tell but also they they
also have higher health
and there comes the imps
yeah there we go yeah
so their health was going up so the Imp
at the end had five health because I
shot it twice with an attack that had
two power and it still had one Health
left so now to make a little bit of
variation there I'm going to change the
base health of the spiders and imps so
they'll operate differently
there he goes now the spiders will have
two Health the imps will have four and
the ghost will have three and then that
will just scale up as they go
but to make them also a little more
different I'm going to change how they
move
so I'm going to affect this event here
and change this to imp ghost
and spider
oh that is the wrong event
here here we go
so I'll make three different versions
for this
change this to ghost
change this to spider
and change this to imp
okay
so now the Imp
will move towards the center at a speed
of eight so it's a little slower but it
has more health
and then the spider will do 12.
[Music]
let's see how much of a difference that
is
see if we want more or less
[Music]
maybe we need a little bit more of a
difference
[Music]
yeah there we go
that should be enough
[Music]
oh you're not stopping
oh
had these backwards
there we go
yeah
great so now we have three different
enemies in game that are a little
different from each other
spawn based on the number of the wave
that we're in and how difficult the game
is
have their health scale to go along with
the difficulty of the game
and it's all working as intended
and now that we have the basic enemies
in the game we're gonna go make each one
seem more unique and then at the very
end of the video we're going to add
mobile controls so then you'll be able
to release this game on desktop or
mobile devices
so let's jump in
now the quickest way to give your
enemies some movement is to use the
Boyd's extension which I kind of overuse
but it's really good for giving basic
enemies some more interesting movement
so we'll just give that behavior to the
ghost enemy
there we go
and now go to enemies
and instead of telling it to move I'm
going to tell it to go towards the
center using the Boyd's extension
I'm going to tell it to go towards an
object
and the object is the center
decision wait we'll just start with 10
and see how that works
and now we'll preview the game
okay that's way too fast and they were
rotating
so let's turn off rotation
and turn down the max speed a lot
and let's see how that works out
there it comes
still too fast
and it's kind of beelining for the
center
so we need to change that as well
let's change the decision weight down to
two and see what that does
[Music]
change it to 0.5
see if that helps
oh there we go
now we're getting that
kind of I'll be there eventually
Behavior
that's what I want
I'm gonna tweak the values a little bit
and then come back
[Music]
okay there we go so I have tweaked the
speeds a little bit and I've changed it
so that now the ghost tries to avoid the
player so when you're playing the game
you can try to chase them off away from
the center
which makes them a much more interesting
and kind of dynamic enemy but also makes
them a little random so
if you get your hands on this game you
might want to tweak the values on these
things
all right now I'm going to do the same
thing to the Imp but I'm going to make
it different on how they approach the
center
I'll give them the same behavior
leave all that alone
I want them to be even slower than the
ghost
not rotate
[Music]
I don't want them to be afraid of the
player
okay and now I'm also going to give them
the fire bullet extension as well
so they can fire at the center
[Music]
there we go
let's make their firing cool down every
four seconds
put one into the scene
going to create a new object Sprite
[Music]
thank you
okay so we'll go here
make a new group
imp
[Music]
and we'll make it so that when the Imp
is
no
we changed the fire rate in the
extension itself or the behavior itself
to four seconds so we need to make it
shoot
or fire bullet
towards a position
from the Imp
oh no wait
fire the bullet
nope here
to fire the bullet
from the Imp
and we'll go from the Imp Center
X and Y
to the center objects
Center
X and Y
and make it go at 50 I guess
okay and we'll see if that works
it should fire up there it is yeah okay
great
uh the
bullets a little bit out of alignment
because I haven't changed the points
changes origin to its Center
now see how it looks
there we go great
and now we'll change this down to 40
and we'll change the imps movement speed
down slower
go 10 and 10.
all right now I want to make this so
that you can block these bullets with
your own body
because why not I can do what I want to
and you can change this if you uh open
the example later and
want a different thing
[Music]
so let's create a new event here
if the enemy bullet is in collision with
the player
delete
enemy bullet
so that way you have a way to combat
these bullets when they fly in
so when they shoot the bullet
yeah I can run into it and stop it
all right
I will want to change the player's
Collision mask I think a little bit
yep
let's bring this down
okay
all right and that is the Imp done
and now for the spider I'm not going to
use boys movement for the spider because
that gives like a floating effect
instead I'm going to use points and
spawn the spider and use the movement
paper that we've already got set up
so I'm going to duplicate this and call
this
the spider spawn
and put a couple points in here
foreign
maybe a couple
more
there we go okay and I'm going to add
another object in
call this shadow
if you've ever seen those hand enemies
the evil hand enemies from Zelda back in
the day this is what I'm doing
adding a new Sprite object call this
drop
great change the center point to the
center
oh wait no no no it needs to be the same
as the spider
so spider's points
its origin is 12 22.
cancel
Shadow points
12 22.
and the drop object
and this is only going to work because
the shadow image and the drop image are
both the exact same size as the spider
image the full size of it
thank you
and now we go to the spawning
and we're going to create both of those
objects shadow
and the drop
move the spider down here
add a weight action
let's say one second
and I need to give both of these objects
the tween Behavior
tween
wait
not between Z order
just a normal tween
okay
drop
add the
tween Behavior
there it is
all right and then tween
uh y position
[Music]
now we'll start with scale
foreign
grow and we'll go to full scale
easing can be linear I guess
again this can be changed because it's
not a big deal
1000 milliseconds and then
destroy
I'm not going to scale from the center
I'm going to scale from the origin I
believe
move this here
[Music]
we're going to change the spot that this
spawns at to the spider spawn point
and the same thing for
the drop object
we'll pick a random
spider spawn point
and we'll do another tween
for the Y position
of the drop object
and call this drop
and we'll go down
we'll go down a hundred so we fall down
a hundred
and again we'll stick with linear
a thousand milliseconds destroy object
when it's done
all right so these here are here
now we need to spawn a
Bove the spider spawn point
100 pixels so that way when we drop we
go
hold on
negative negative is up
and so that way when we drop we go from
100 Above Down
to the actual position itself
[Music]
also spawn at the same spider spawner
what's gonna happen is we're going to
spawn these objects between them to the
right position
and then have the spider spawn at those
positions when they get destroyed
by the tweening event
I'm going to change this to zero for
right now to make it Force the spiders
to spawn first
hey there's one
okay all right
so they are dropping
not exactly greatly but they're dropping
properly
what's not happening is a scale event
so we'll scale the Sprite object
of The Shadow
to zero
so then it's going to start at zero and
go to Tween up so let's try that
oh there we go
there's another one
so that looks like they're falling from
the ceiling
I'm going to change the position of that
spawning point though because that's a
bit weird let's change the spawning
point to the center
there we go and
[Music]
perfect
oh I'm going to actually beginning of
scene
hide those spider spawners
so they're still there we just can't see
them
okay cool
and now you can see the spiders are
dropping
and because the object that's dropping
is not the spider itself I can't shoot
it
all right great so now we have three
unique enemies that all act differently
the ghost kind of hovers around and the
Enders its way to the center the spider
runs towards the center after dropping
from the ceiling and the Imp will
actually fire a fireball that I didn't
code properly
hold on
okay game over
we'll also add if the enemy bullet hits
the center game over so we need to use
or
and then put this inside of the ore
condition
so now
if the enemy gets to the center or if
the enemy bullet gets to the center it's
game over and we start over
now let me just play test that to make
sure it actually works
and as a nice twist the ghosts now being
afraid of you means that they won't go
towards the center so you'll kind of
have an ever increasing swarm of ghosts
around the center until you choose to
run off and grab the experience points
or run off to try to protect the center
from one of the Fireballs
now there's one thing I did notice
though
and that's that these enemies aren't
necessarily looking the right way
anymore because the code has changed for
how they spawn
so
I'm going to need to change this
forever so they won't just do it when
they spawn they'll do it always
okay now I need to fix a bug that
somebody mentioned in one of the earlier
comments
um the
leveling up layer exists whether or not
you can see it
so even during gameplay if you click
where that button is on screen you will
get that level up without the experience
points required
okay so the buttons clicked so we need
to add a second condition here for
um
if the layer is currently visible
so we can search for visibility
visibility of a layer the leveling up
layer
so we will only be able to click on the
button if the leveling up layer is
actually showing
so that bug is now fixed
great now the last thing I want to do in
this video before I run out of time is
ADD mobile controls because people have
been asking for that and it's really
quick so watch this
joystick
I like these joysticks
okay we'll create another layer call
this mobile controls
uh we'll call this
movement
plop this down shrink it down a little
bit because it's a bit big
you can find the size you want
maybe a little bigger there we go
and then I will duplicate this
and call it aiming
all right so now movement and aiming
for the player I'm going to go to
behaviors
add a behavior and once you've added a
joystick you should have
top down multi-touch controller mapper
top down movement analog great
so I've added the behavior to the player
I press preview
ah
I've got to put the object on the layer
right
mobile controls okay preview
down Behavior plus this plus the mapper
behavior and it works
now for aiming let's plop this one down
make it the same size so 96 by 96
and roughly the same spot
okay all right now for this it's going
to be a little bit trickier but
we'll collapse all of this go to the
player go to gun
check if this is a mobile device
and change this to not
make a new action move that there
all right so if it's not a mobile device
we will rotate the gun towards the
cursor
if it is a mobile device we will rotate
the gun towards the angle
angular speed zero
angle of that joystick so joystick
stick angle
I think it's
two
and secondary
we will make sure that's right so we go
to here
go to aiming
change this to 2 and make this secondary
all right
and so now
because I'm on a laptop and this is not
a mobile device
I'm going to just remove that condition
really quickly and disable that
just for testing
huh
and put this on the mobile control layer
[Music]
there we go so now the gun AIMS in the
direction of the joystick
great
[Music]
okay so this will work it's just
the problem is that it's fighting two
conflicting orders so
we will copy these
[Music]
and disable both of these right now
just for testing
and there we go now the gun and the
player rotate with the joystick
because we're using the condition
joystick pushed in a direction and then
using the proper number and joystick
name
and then the direction
so if it's pushing right it's going to
not flip and if it's pushing left it
will flip
just like when the cursor was on one
side or the other of the player
and now we will use the condition
mobile device
and again but inverted
[Music]
all right
and then put this here and
we are good so if it's not a mobile
device it's going to use
the cursor's position if it is a mobile
device
it will rotate towards the joysticks
angle
and then for the flipping this will
happen
we do need to change it though so that
or
two here
either the left joystick
or Mouse button is down
no hold on
and
okay
back to the mobile device thing
so if it's not a mobile device this is
an and condition
if the left Mouse button is pushed down
and it's not a mobile device
then this will be true
this is an ore condition
so if that is true or
the joystick is pushed down
let's try that okay so if it's above
zero if the force on the joystick is
above zero so it's being moved at all
yeah so when I'm clicking anywhere else
doesn't work holding the joystick does
work
so I've got movement and joystick
we'll change that back to not a mobile
device
and we have our controls all set up
sorry if it looks a little bit
complicated but you need to have
separate controls for mobile and not
mobile so
all right
that's the game
we'll move this down below the
transition so you can't see it when you
first start the game
and we will set it up so that
copy this
if it is not a mobile device
we will just delete the mobile controls
which are movement
and aiming
so now when I start the game and it's
not a mobile device because it's my
laptop
they're gone and the game plays normally
all right
and that has been the entire series I'm
making a wave defense game